okay it is a very special day today in
that it is a day for hatred mail here's
a reminder of what hatred mail is
because we cling to our guns and our God
but somehow totally cool with a
billionaire who wants to assault our
wife Patriot man written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman right because America
and because freedom
all right this week's hatred mail
doesn't really need any specific
introduction let's just get right into
it and see if we can figure it out
together you are a very special kind of
stupid I bet you and this David Park man
clown love to do 69s in your mommy's
basements with your goddamn it's comfort
mother gherkins Park man should find
something else to do with his time
bottom of the food chain
other than totally depraved in every way
a very special kind of stupid isn't a
badly put together insult like there's a
slight it's what when it comes to its
its literary value which is normally
less than zero when it comes to hatred
mail a very special kind of stupid is
poetic in a sense and again I'm just
trying to find something here that is
not vile and completely depraved and
retrograde and backwards and that is
something there other than referring to
me as Parkman twice which of course what
is Parkman this is this this is the
David Pakman show a very special kind of
stupid has some redeeming nature to it I
like I bet all one word Det it sounds
like a fashion line of some sort yeah
yeah it does and yet another hate reott
who has managed to simultaneously expose
that they know very little about what
this show even is it's Parkman used as
an insult because I see that a lot and I
don't know if they're making a mistake
or I think there's too little reference
I think some people probably aren't used
to seeing the last name Pakman because
it's a pretty unusual last name and they
may be wrongly think oh did the David
Parkman
there also might be an autocorrect
component don't you think it's possible
yeah but well he certainly didn't use
spellcheck so he wouldn't go back and
check over his work but if it
autocorrected what he was typing out oh
that's a good you think he would change
the other things you see I'm saying yeah
yeah it's probably not an autocorrect
issue now that you're you're saying that
yeah hey listen you can turn hatred mail
into something positive if you want to
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership there is a
coupon code which is hey tree at 40 all
one word all lowercase H atri ot for
zero and it will give you a big li
tremendous discount off of a david
pakman show membership